all right we're back with the amazing
Dove Cameron and joining us is Drew crew
it's a burnout hello
hi everyone and Eton and Dove are about
to bravely taste some really weird stuff
because it's our thing Eton and I've
been doing it since the beginning weird
food Combos and Dove we got to kick it
off with a childhood favorite when I
heard about this my heart like Swoon it
sounds really good honestly I have I
have to say I think I still stand by
this my dad used to make this for me I
have no idea why we just have like a
surplus of rainbow sprinkles so it is
bagel with cream cheese and rainbow
sprinkles yeah it doesn't sound that
weird to me it just sounds delicious I
think I think it will be delicious yeah
I'm doing it okay here we go
there is nothing wrong about that tell
me that doesn't smack that's real good
sweet and savory yeah it's like you've
got a little bit of sweetness from the
sprinkles it's kind of just like a
little dessert version of bagels and
creams you know how like you know like
cupcakes have like cream cheese frosting
I was gonna say all cakes seem to have a
cream cheese twist on it now which I
love because it's got a little bit of
that tang and then a little bit of sweet
and who doesn't love a bagel I mean yeah
then paying this for me just well in
honor of your dad love thank you for the
best new latest food combo
we love you Phil all right next we've
got the latest Tick Tock food debate if
you cucumber into sugar does it taste
like watermelon
does it I don't know okay
we're bravely typing in all right let's
see yeah cheers here we go
hmm
it's not bad it's not offensive no
there's it's nice yeah it tastes good
but I wouldn't say it tastes like like a
watermelon so no watermelon sugar eggs
no no
thank you Harry Styles sorry Harry but
no I mean it's delicious okay and for
the food finale we've got my favorite
there is a new trend about macaroni and
cheese and now people are putting
applesauce on their macaroni and cheese
nope which gives me kind of a blitzy
Vibe okay can I spin it that way because
I love a cheese Blends you can try an
apple sauce we'll be the judge though
yeah try it and tell me because I'm a
purist and I'm doubtful but I'm also
kind of intrigued I'm a mac and cheese
pure yeah I hope it doesn't ruin mac and
cheese I know this I'm a little bit
afraid of
I got a lot of friendships but not good
I'm gonna say not offensive but not
strong not something I ever need to have
no but up to one bite one bite and gun
and that's a one bite and done so the
reviews are in
music
two three
especially Phil Cameron's uh Dove's dad
I was gonna say Phil Cameron uh Doug's
dad uh Phil his I think is number one
hands down the winner
late night
s possibilities are unless sentimental
convo a good snack what more could you
need and
Dove schmagadoon is just amazing your
first season is so strong this new
season I love our I love her so much
because you love it so much I love her
so much I feel her I feel her now is
available today on Apple TV plus and up
next it's raffle time someone in our
audience is going to go home with an
e-bike which is exciting
um if it was me I'd be all over the
place and crashing but that's a whole
other story we'll be right back
with the amazing Dove Cameron and
joining us is Drew crew hello
in this show since day one and Eton and
Dove are about to bravely taste some
really weird stuff because it's our
thing Eton and I've been doing it since
the beginning weird food Combos and Dove
we gotta kick it off with a childhood
favorite when I heard about this my
heart like Swoon it sounds really good
honestly I have I have to say I think I
still stand by this my dad used to make
this for me I have no idea why we just
have like a surplus of rainbow sprinkles
so it is bagel with cream cheese and
rainbow sprinkles yeah it doesn't sound
that weird to me it just sounds
delicious I think I think it will be
delicious yeah I'm doing it okay here we
go
there's nothing wrong about that tell me
that doesn't smack that's real good
sweet and savory yeah it's like we've
got a little bit of sweetness from the
sprinkles it's kind of just like a
little dessert version of bagels and
creams you know how like you know like
cupcakes have like cream cheese frosting
I was gonna say all cakes seem to have a
cream cheese twist on it now which I
love because it's got a little bit of
that tang and then a little bit of sweet
and who doesn't love a bagel I mean yeah
then paying this meanest well in honor
of your dad no thank you for the best
new latest food combo
we love you Phil all right next we've
got the latest Tick Tock food debate if
you cucumber into sugar does it taste
like watermelon
does it I don't know okay
we're bravely typing in all right let's
see yeah cheers here we go
hmm
it's not bad it's not offensive yeah
there's it's nice yeah it tastes good
but I wouldn't say it tastes like like a
watermelon so no watermelon sugar eggs
no no no
thank you Harris Styles sorry Harry but
no I mean it's delicious okay and for
the food finale we've got my favorite
there is a new trend about macaroni and
cheese and now people are putting
applesauce on their macaroni and cheese
nope which gives me kind of a blimcy
Vibe okay can I spin it that way because
I love a cheese Blends you can try an
apple sauce we'll be the judge though
yeah try it and tell me because I'm a
purist and I'm doubtful but I'm also
kind of intrigued I'm a mac and cheese
pure yeah I hope this doesn't ruin mac
and cheese I know this I'm a little bit
afraid of
I got a lot of friendships but not good
I'm gonna say not offensive but not
strong not something I ever need to have
no idea but up to one bite one bite and
done and that's a one bite and done so
the reviews are in
music
actually Phil Cameron's uh Dove's dad I
was gonna say Phil Cameron uh God's dad
uh Phil his I think is number one hands
down the winner
possibilities are almost sentimental
convo a good snack what more could you
need and Dove schmagadoon is just
amazing your first season is so strong
I love her I love her so much that you
love it love it I love so much I feel
high I feel her now is available today
on Apple TV plus and up next it's raffle
time someone in our audience is going to
go home with an e-bike which is exciting
um if it was me I'd be all over the
place and crashing but that's a whole
other story we'll be right back
thank you
[Music]